Big Data is not an unmitigated good like
many things in society,
in fact,
probably all things,
it comes with risks as well and it comes
with a dark side and one dark side of
course is privacy that exists today.
It'll exist tomorrow.
Maybe it gets bigger with big data as
well,
but there is something else to play for
something else that's a little bit more
troubling still and that is if you will
propensity it,
is big data algorithms making a
prediction of what you are likely to do
before you've actually done it.
Now the criminal justice system has
never really dealt with this sort of
problem before.
Typically you have to commit a crime
before you were penalized for that
crime,
but what if it is simply a prediction
that you have a likelihood of committing
a crime?
Would society be remiss not to
intervene?
If I could tell with a 98 percent
statistical accuracy that you are likely
to shoplift in the next 12 months?
Public Safety requires that I interact
and maybe I don't put you into jail.
It's not minority report.
It's not pre crime.
I have a social worker knock on your
door and say,
we'd like to help you.
We'd like to get you an afterschool job.
If you're a teenager,
we'd like to sort of support you.
Well,
that sounds like it's a benefit,
but in reality,
if you think about it,
this person is going to be stigmatized
in the eye of his peers,
school teachers,
parents,
in fact,
he'll probably feel stigmatized in his
own eyes and feel badly,
and we might even encourage the tort
sort of behavior that we want to
prevent.
The point is that he will have been a
victim of a prediction about him and he
could rightly say,
I will be the two percent that will not
a shoplift that I'll exercise my moral
choice.
So the solution seems to be in a big
data world.
We want to send how sanctify the notion
of the human volition of human free will
and to preserve that as a central
attribute.